los votantes franceses eligen
directamente a su presidente por
sufragio universal el voto es abierto
para todos los ciudadanos franceses
mayores de 18 años siempre que no estén
legalmente inhabilitados para votar y
estén inscritos en la lista electoral
las mismas reglas se aplican a los
candidatos quienes también deben mostrar
un sentido de dignidad moral un término
vago sin una definición legal clara y
reunir 500 firmas de apoyo de
representantes electos
cualquiera que cumpla con estos
criterios es elegible para participar en
la primera ronda si nadie gana con una
mayoría absoluta más del 50 por ciento
de los votos los candidatos con mayor
puntuación se enfrentan en una segunda
vuelta aquí es donde entra a jugar el
voto estratégico en la segunda ronda
muchos votantes elegirán a un candidato
que inicialmente no apoyaron para
bloquear a otro contendiente esto
sucedió por primera vez en 2002 cuando
el ultraderechista jean-marie le pen
llegó inesperadamente a la segunda ronda
su oponente el titular de entonces
jacques chirac obtuvo más del 82% de los
votos el mayor margen en la historia del
país